Football Hall of Famer Howie long how
are ya Lee I'm good rich I don't recall
hearing you that [ __ ] dove well I mean
I don't know what just you know Howie
it's it's I don't know what to make a
last night's game you know oh boy
and I figured we'd call you up as a guy
who has been in the trenches whose sons
are in the trenches and as what what you
thought of the action last night well
the roughing the passer stuff I you know
we we have Mike Prayer and D Blandino in
our studio and you know more often than
I'm young Dean what's that right and
here's the concerning part I'm sure
you've seen it too that at an alarming
rate the calls that go back to New York
for review are coming back wrong and
that's scary and you know people you you
win and lose games on calls like that
and and and in some cases you lose your
job you know I don't know where to start
last night did you juice that you do
play was it it's definitively outside
the bounds of how the game is played
today in the not so distant past it was
standard operating procedure the part
that I didn't get and you know there's a
young guy who you know is being
indoctrinated to and it's a whole nother
conversation the AFC North and Baltimore
Pittsburgh Cincinnati Pittsburgh you
know it's it's a man's division and it's
a physical division and they pride
themselves on that and they asked no
quarter and they give no quarter and
certainly bonta's Burfict has been in in
the middle of a number of controversial
hits and plays over the course of the
last four or five years and there's a
lot of bad blood here in this in this
matchup in particular and the part that
I probably would have liked to see more
and I'm not sure I haven't talked to my
career Dean Blandino yet but given that
it's a Monday night game and you know
not to diminish Sunday games but that
it's a Monday night game and you know
the kind of bad blood there is in this
matchup I'm over calling the game early
and ironically enough what ends up
happening you know on the run on the
sideline the bell run up the sideline is
and it's kind of where quarterbacks are
sliding they're not sliding do I pull up
do I look bad what if he doesn't slide
he decides the kind of delays slide he
picks up the extra yard picks up the
first down the other thing is the
sideline how do I deal with the sideline
and last night was a great example of
that on the touchdown run
III think both I think to the players
thought that he was out of bounds and
they pull off because you're concerned
about getting that flag in a key
situation and potentially losing you
know 10 15 $50,000 interest of your
money and potentially being suspended
yeah I mean I didn't I didn't
think of the fact that reason why that
he went up the sideline untouched wasn't
you know lazy play but just they that
the flags were out and all of that but
the sideline is very difficult to deal
with now you know and I see hits that
are beyond the sidelines and you say
well why didn't expect that and then I
see hits that take place right on the
line that I don't believe should be
called and if you're going to kind of
okey-doke me on the sideline you know
you get what you're you have coming to
you well then let me ask you this how E
because it was asked directly of Marvin
Lewis last night that if the league is
done essentially all it can do to clean
the game up and tell you you know what
you're gonna get fined for best they can
and and and and put it on the defender
sometimes to to not do it although we
saw last night juju Smith Schuster get
called for it that's something part of
it rich bothered me
ben's comment was it kind of sums it up
and it's coming from a quarterback but
I've granted a66 250-pound quarterback
AFC North football but a lot of people
were offended by that Hallie and you
know what Richard it is what it is I
mean it it's like if you're a Philly
boxer you're a different kind of boxer
you know a lot of times your your your
most taxing fights are in the gym
they're not in the ring on on fight
night I'm gonna give me the opposing
point of view then and you could say or
is that is that is that Ben certainly as
a quarterback should say you know it's a
nasty game but this got too out of hand
tonight and we need to clean this up as
players because people are saying this
to Howie they asked it directly of
Marvin last night that if the league has
made these rules changes and and the
refs are calling it and it's still
happening should it now fall on the
players themselves to understand what's
happening here in police themselves on
the player safety front well I you know
I think a it all starts at the top it
starts with your head coach and it
filters down to your coordinator and
your offensive line coach I mean they're
been offensive line coach throughout the
course of my career both as a player and
a broadcaster in the NFL particularly
during my career who were just the
dirtiest son of [ __ ] you could
possibly imagine who in their head were
their goal was to get 7 to 10 knees a
year
think about that rich so you know it's
been part of football but I play ER in
my mind acts out on the field how he's
coached and that's head coach and and
the grog thing was an anomaly that this
weekend auto line should have been
suspended frustrated don't care it's
there's no place for it
do players have tempers yeah you know I
got one
who's got a pretty good temper but you
got to reel it in and I think it starts
with the coaches it's it's the head
coach it's the coordinator it's the
position coach who's teaching the
players how to play and it's making it
unacceptable to play outside the bounds
of the way the Games supposed to be
played
you got to play physical you got to make
the big hit now as I mentioned there are
situations that you're putting players
in a real quandary the slide thing the
flacco slide I didn't see anything wrong
with that
the Alonso hit on him I didn't see
anything wrong with that because awkward
slide and late how does the sixth sixth
guy go from vertical to hit the ground
he's not Russell Wilson people like
Russell Wilson can get down quick cam
struggles to get down Flacco really
struggles to get down my gosh it was
painful to watch but and and then the
contact ends up being head to head and
and that's where the issue comes in but
the players the defenders are being put
in a bad spot on the crossing routes the
deep routes the sidelines run by the
quarterback in particular but running
backs or wide receivers when do I pull
off is he going to let up is he going to
go out of bounds or is it going to make
me look bad and pick up three more yards
because when I walk in that meeting on
Monday morning I gotta watch that film
in front of the whole team so when it
all comes down to it how we walk me
through the process is it possible to
player that's making an instinctive play
can instinctively place that aside and
have the wits about them to not take a
shot that they know could lead somebody
to get hurt that possible you know you'd
have to be more specific with me I I'm
I'm as a general rule I think it's it's
the questions too vague
I think situation by situation the
grunting out of control Judy's a young
player you know
hopefully he'll learn from one the hit
and two the taunting and that won't
happen again I'm sure won't he seems to
be a really solid kid and a kid with a
really bright future III think it's it's
incumbent upon the coaches to demand
that the players play within the rules
and and you see teams that that where
that's the case and I go back to New
England it's just not your if you make a
play like that
how frightening are you to go into a
meeting on Monday with Bill Belichick
it's funny how we read the comedian and
actor Dennis Leary on yesterday said the
same thing
I play Michael strand I had the same
defensive line coach Earl Leggett
brought both of us up if there's no
world leggett there's no Michael Strahan
there's no Howie Long if we did anything
I'm talking about effort technique a
level of play the way you play the game
if we did anything that was wrong I just
sleep Sunday night if I just got hooked
once I didn't sleep Sunday night so I'm
not sure that there's not a lot of Earl
legate's out there that that's part of
the problem and the other problem is I
got I got to keep it real what does that
mean keep it real I play the game be
physical be tough but don't go beyond I
mean if there's if it's a bang-bang play
rich and a receiver ducked his head at
the last second I get it I kind of see
it I feel for the safety I feel for the
wide receivers getting hit but I feel
for the safety - I feel for the
linebacker I feel for the guy on the
sideline who's not sure whether this guy
is going to go out of bounds or he's
gonna make me look bad fake like he's
going out of bounds and pick up two more
yards in the first down could be a
difference maker in the game
I'd love to have you back on later this
month in the instead of after a game
like this cuz the NFC still wide open
its common it's really great hiding and
I guess if you have just one extra
minute who do you see winning the NFC
with the Vikings now playing his way
they have and there they went out they
got that one seat
how can you keep him he's got the
slipper on he's you know what the last
two weeks and there were two totally
different ball games he played great two
weeks ago I mean played great made some
big plays they went down there with a
plan we're gonna play great defense
we're gonna get them off the field on
third down we're gonna give them their
yards on the ground but we're going to
hold them to X amount of points don't
make the hero mistake a quarterback in
case extended plays they ran the ball
efficiently they got just enough and it
was a great win on the road Minnesota is
a tough out right now Seattle you know
you know we talked about it on our show
the consensus was they're not an elite
defense anymore they're in at least
front seven and they've got a Hall of
Fame safety and they've got a couple of
young quarterbacks who were pretty good
as we came to find out this past week
the Rams are a team that you know III
people I know whether people just think
there are novelty or what but they're
punting game they're kicking game
they're defensive front
Aaron Donald's the best defensive tackle
in football I know it's so running back
offensive line they they had a charter
come in from Buffalo at the receiving
corps you know tight end the quarterback
all the sudden he looked like a guy who
was lost a year ago and now all of a
sudden he's one of the most accurate
quarterbacks in football and the head
coach he's changing the way everyone
thinks about who do we hire next that's
true how I love chat with you let's
let's chat later on this month before
the new camera I love it thanks Howie
that's how he long the Vikings are about
to on the verge of doing something
nobody's done in the Superbowl Erica
will hit that review a little bit more
what Howie just said when we come back
the Rich Eisen show weekdays
noon eastern on audience